Looking to Netflix and chill this weekend?
We've got just the thing.
Catch all these killer films before they leave
the streaming platform possibly for good.
Each of these titles will be gone by September
1st, so time is of the essence here.
Godspeed!
The Hangover redefined the comedy genre when
it stormed into theaters in 2009.
Starring Bradley Cooper, Ed Helms, Doug Billings,
and Zach Galifianakis, the film follows four
theoretically upstanding young men as they
descend upon Las Vegas for a bachelor party.
But the night they arrive, these standup dudes
get fall-down drunk... and wake up the next
morning with no recollection of the night
before.
What's worse, the groom-to-be has mysteriously
gone missing.
"I looked everywhere.
Gym, casino, the front desk — nobody has
seen Doug.
He's not here."
Now, it's a race against time as everyone
scrambles to retrace their steps and find
Doug before his fiancée figures out what's
going on.
"Where's Doug?"
"He is… paying the bill.
We just had a delicious brunch and we're in
a big hurry to get back so we gotta be going!"
Throughout their quest, they encounter some
intensely strange and unsavory characters,
all while suffering from the mother of all
hangovers.
The Hangover will be staggering away from
Netflix on September 1st.
It's the film that reinvigorated the Batman
property after the critical and commercial
failure of 1997's Batman and Robin.
Released in 2005, Batman Begins stars Christain
Bale as Bruce Wayne, a dark and brooding gentleman
who witnessed the brutal murder of his parents
as a child.
Wayne eventually becomes a full-fledged vigilante,
determined to wipe crime off the streets of
Gotham City.
Operating under the guise of Batman, the caped
crusader battles the nefarious psychiatrist
Dr. Jonathan Crane, portrayed by Cillian Murphy.
"Psychopharmacology is my …”
“In here only the mind can grant you power."
Otherwise known as Scarecrow, this iconic
baddie is hellbent on plunging the city into
the depths of chaos.
The question is: Will he succeed?
Find out before Batman Begins flies away from
Netflix on September 1st.
Hey, here's an idea: Why not turn your evening
into a dark and disturbing double feature?
You simply can't go wrong with The Dark Knight,
the 2008 sequel to Batman Begins.
This time, Batman takes on one of his most
notorious rivals: The Joker, played to perfection
by the late Heath Ledger.
"Why so serious?"
Throughout the film, the maniacal madman commits
countless crimes, undercutting Batman's status
in Gotham and plunging the city into complete
and utter darkness.
This time, the question is: Has Batman finally
met his match?
It's the perfect time to reacquaint yourself
with Ledger's iconic performance.
On October 4th, Todd Phillips' Joker film
will give us a freaky new spin on the Clown
Prince of Crime, portrayed by the always captivating
Joaquin Phoenix.
“Haha.”
The Dark Knight will be zipping away from
Netflix on September 1st.
Sweeney Todd: The Demon Barber of Fleet Street
is probably one of Tim Burton's weirdest and
most wonderful movies and that's saying a
lot considering all the outlandish oddities
he's made in the past.
A silver screen translation of Stephen Sondheim
and Hugh Wheeler's musical of the same name,
Sweeney Todd features Johnny Depp in the title
role, a barber-slash-serial killer who cuts
the hair and throats of his customers with
his signature straight razor.
Meanwhile, Todd's right-hand woman Mrs. Nellie
Lovett portrayed by Burton's ex-wife and frequent
collaborator Helena Bonham Carter uses his
"leftovers" as the main ingredient in her
special meat pies.
"What are we going to do about the boy, then?"
"Send him up."
"Oh, we don't need to worry about him — he's
a simple thing."
The film slashed its way to the top of the
box office in December 2007, earning $152
million worldwide against its $50 million
production budget, raking in dazzling reviews
from critics.
A National Board of Review-selected pick for
the top 10 movies of the year, Sweeney Todd
also took home numerous Golden Globe Awards
and an Academy Award for Best Art Direction.
Sweeney Todd leaves Netflix on September 1st,
so check it out now before it's too late.
Chop chop!
Eager for more Fast and Furious in your life
after catching the franchise spinoff Hobbs
& Shaw?
Plan a back-to-back-to-back binge session
of three Fast and Furious films that won't
be available to stream on Netflix for much
longer.
They're going, going, GONE, baby.
"Where's he going?"
"Went to the carwash."
"...go have him fetch my car."
"Go fetch your car?"
The first three entries in the high-octane
series are skidding away from Netflix on September
1st: The Fast and the Furious, 2 Fast 2 Furious,
and The Fast and the Furious: Tokyo Drift.
If you're looking for a mindless adrenaline
rush, you simply can't go wrong with this
franchise.
But you better get a move on...
Adapted from Anthony Burgess's novel of the
same name, Stanley Kubrick's dark futuristic
fantasy A Clockwork Orange follows the exploits
of a charismatic young sociopath named Alex,
played with insidious glee by Malcolm McDowell.
"Oh, jolly good."
Alex and his merry band of thugs commit "ultra-violence"
wherever they go, until Alex is finally thrown
in jail following one of his intensely heinous
crimes.
In order to return to society, he agrees to
undergo rehabilitation through psychological
conditioning.
And when he's finally back on the streets,
it's Alex's turn to be the victim… or is
it?
Whether revisiting the film or checking it
out for the first time, you simply won't be
able to take your eyes off the screen.
Check out A Clockwork Orange before it leaves
Netflix on September 1st… because it would
be a crime to miss it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.